[Music]
you are going to be in the next
Transformers yes movie which was a big
deal for my kids I would think now
you've brought done other stuff I'm sure
your kids like but this must be a huge
deal with them yeah oh they actually
they really wanted to see Ted as well
the boys are into anything with me with
a gun too but my daughters was excited
for the first time to the point where
they asked if they could be in the movie
and I asked Michael Bay if he would put
them in the movie and he did I don't
know if they're gonna make the final cut
but they're in the movie it's the first
time they were excited about the movie
but now the girls have turned to one
direction and it's like they don't care
about dad anymore my four-year-olds
going daddy I like Hayley and I'm the
woman to punch Harry in the nose when I
see and I'm like oh you're gonna punch
Harrigan yes and I know she pulls out
pictures of him and she's hiding
pictures in the room and I pretend that
I'm gonna rip them up and I get jealous
but if I see that little prick okay hey
you know I really want to meet one
direction I'm a big fan invite them to
Transformers premiere maybe you can do
this title track for the song and then I
beat the crap out of them in a video
you're gonna lure One Direction to help
you with a project get them into a room
and then beat the crap out of Harry
yeah probably all five of them but no
you know what I am gonna make a point to
try to get my daughters to meet them
right I'd rather do it now my oldest is
10 and she's into them as well right and
that would be the only time I'll ever
introduce them to a boy and after that
it gets it's the locked out as Rapunzel
time yes literally put them in a tower
yeah